[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم تلاحقت خطابات الرئيس اليمني
المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح بشكل لافت
للنظر متارجحه بين الدعوه لمزيد من الحشد
والنفير في صفوف القبائل والمطالبه بدفع
مزيد من المقاتلين نحو الجبهات والهجوم
على حزب التجمع للاصلاح والتوعد بملاحقه
منتسبيه واشت فافهم من نسيج المجتمع
اليمني حرب نحو الداخل هي التي تتشكل في
خطاب صالح مفاتيحها التحريض والمزيد من
التحريض غير ان السؤال الاساس يبقى اي صدا
لمثل هذه
الدعوات مخبين خلال ثلاثه اساب
تلاحقت خطابات الرئيس اليمني المخلوع علي
عبد الله صالح بعد ان كان متواريا عن
الانظار لا يظهر الا لمامه وحرص على
مخاطبه انصاره باستخدام لغه تصعيديه
مفاتيحها الجبهات والحشود والالتفاف
والمزيد من المعارك ففي اللقاء الاخير له
وقبل مرور الدقيقه الاولى من بدايه خطابه
انبرى الى مقصده الاساسي وبهذه
المناسبه
ادعو محافظ صنعا وكل
المحافظات الى رفض
الجبهات
بالمقاتلين اما الجبهات التي يريد صالح
اذكاء نيران الحروب فيها ويرغب في الدفع
بمقاتلي نحوها فقد لمح اليها ثم صرح جبهات
الحدود مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وفيما بدا استراتيجيه للاقناع
كشف صالح عن الحلول التي اعتبرها الانجع
لتعويض النقص في القوات المواليه له عندكم
مقاتلين
اشداء الذي شملتهم هيكله هادي وهم
العسكريين في بيوتهم وانا اعرفهم حق معرفه
400 الف م هي رسائل متقاطعه اذا تلتقي
كلها عند تحريض اتباعه وحلفائه على مزيد
من الاحتراب الداخلي لكن الرئيس اليمني
المخلوعه خص حزب الاصلاح بانه الاولى
بالقتال عيا لمطار اعضائه والقضاء عليهم
الخونه
والمرتزقه من
مخلفات
مخلفات تنظيم الارهاب الاخوان المسلمين
بين قوسين
الاصلاح لهجه صالح والرسائل المعلنه وتلك
المشفره في خطاباته يعيد بها تاكيد ما بدا
استراتيجيته المفضله وهي الدفع بالاخرين
للجبهات او للتاجيل الشهاده وهنا يتسا
يمنيون كثر ماذا يريد الرئيس المخلوع من
تصدره المشهد كقائد ميداني والى ماذا تشير
خطاباته التصعيد تلك ترى تحليلات ان دعوته
لتكثيف القتال على الحدود مع السعوديه
تاتي لتاج المشاعر والهاء اتباعه بموضوع
الاستقلال والسياده الوطنيه التي فرط هو
نفسه فيها وهو ذات الخطاب التعبوي
للحوثيين وتذهب قراءات اخرى الى لان
خطابات صالح تاتي في وقت مل فيه اليمنيون
منه وقد حكم البلاد
33 عاما واوصلها لما وصلت اليه ولا يزال
يتشبث بالسلطه وضاق اليمنيون باستمرار
الحرب دون افق لحل النهائي وباتوا يعانون
من الوضع الاقتصادي المتا ازم عوده الرئيس
اليمني هادي والحكومه الى البلاد وتردي
الوضع الاقتصادي ومال المعارك في اكثر من
جبهه كلها تبدو عوا متفره تؤدي لاضعاف
تاثير الرئيس المخلوع
صالح اناقش خطاب صالح مع الدكتور عادل
الشجاع عضو اللجنه العامه في حزب المؤتمر
الشعبي العام اليمني جناح علي عبد الله
صالح الذي ينضم الينا من عمان ومن اسطنبول
مع خالد الانسي الناشط الحقوقي اليمني
وعضو ائتلاف شباب الثوره اليمنيه اهلا بكم
ما خالد الانسي ما دلالات تركيز الرئيس
المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح على الدفع
والزج بابناء القبائل الى الجبهات خاصه
الجبهات الشماليه مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه واضح انه خطاب يعني خطاب مازوم
يذكرنا بخطابات القذافي قبل السقوطه يعني
ظهر الرئيس المخلوع في هذا الخطاب كشخص
دموي غير مبالي بدماء اليمنيين ظهر كزعيم
فعلي للانقلاب وكقائد فعلي للانقلاب
اي ايضا هنالك كان في الخطاب يركز على
حمايه صنعاء وهنا يدل على انه اصبح يعني
كل همه بدرجه رئيسيه حمايه نفسه في صنعاء
وهنا مفارقه لما كان قبل ثلاث سنوات وهو
الرئيس هادي عندما كان داخل صنعاء محاصر
وغير قادر على التحرك وكان هذه القبائل
التي يدعوها اليوم الرئيس المخلوع لحمايته
التي يستخدمها في السابق
لمحاصرته الان يعاني ويظهر نفسه كقائد
للانقلاب بعد ان فشل في التواريخ خلف و
حركه الحوثي في تلبيس انقلابه بهذه الحركه
الان ظهر كعدو حقيقي هو قدم نفسه كشريك في
الحرب على الارهاب كصديق للسعوديه كمدافع
عنها اظهر نفسه في هذا الخطاب كعدو
للسعوديه وانه من كان يعت يقدمهم للسعوديه
انهم اعداء هم في حقيقه الامر يعني هم من
يدافعون عن اليمن وهم من يبحثون عن ش
شراكه حقيقيه مع السعوديه ويبحثون عن بناء
يمن المواطنه المتساويه هو خطاب فيه افلاس
يعني بشكل واضح يعني دكتور دكتور عادل
الشجاع اللافت في خطاب الرئيس المخلوع علي
عبد الله صالح انه لا يدعو فقط للقتال في
الجبهات وانما ايضا الى قتال ربما فئوي
مجتمعي بين اصلاحي وحوث واشتراك ومؤتمر
الى اخره الى اين يؤدي هذا بالمجتمع
اليمني وببلاش
عام
القتال الجاري حاليا هو بين مكونات
المجتمع اليمني بشكل عام واعتقد ان
المتصارعين الان على الساحه هم كل هذه
الاحزاب والمكونات السياسيه سواء كانوا من
المؤتمر الشعبي العام او من حزب الاصلاح
او حتى من الناصري والاشتراكي وال وكذلك
بالنسبه للسلفيين ومن ينكر ذلك في اعتقادي
انما يغطي على عين الشمس الح في اليمن
وصلت الى مرحله ان الصراع اصبح صراعا
مجتمعيا والاطراف جميعها تدفع في هذا
الاتجاه وما
نسمعه من خلال المعارك التي تدور بين
الحين والاخر سواء في منطقه المخاء او في
منطقه نيم في مارب في البيضاء هي في
الاساس صراع يشمل كل هذه المكونات التي
ذكرتها في سؤالك وفي اعتقادي انه ما يجري
اليوم لا لا يرتبط بطرف من الاطراف بقدر
ما كل الاطراف هي شريكه في هذا الصراع وال
والذي يفترض ان يطرح اليوم هو الدعوه
للمصالحه العامه واعتقد ان الرئيس هكذا
خطاب دكتور هل يمكن الحديث عن مصالحه عامه
في ظل هذا الخطاب والدعوه الى اطال فئوي
واجتماعي داخلي يعني هو يطلب من ابن العم
ان ان ان ان ان يقتل ربما ابن عمه او او
قريبه او وجاري حتى في في المحافظه
الواحده وفي القريه الواحده اذا ما كان
اصلاحيا ا يخذ الخطاب في سياقه انا حينما
سمعت الخطاب وجهت رساله للرئيس السابق
وانتقدت هذا التوجه فاتضح لي بان السياق
الكلام كان موجه لقيادات معينه تحاول في
الوقت الراهن ان تثير الاختلالات الامنيه
وتحديدا في محافظه صنعاء وبالتالي كان
الخطاب موجه لها وليس للاصلاح بشكل عام
لان الرئيس السابق يدرك بان كثير من
الاصلاحيين ضد العدوان على اليمن وايضا هم
ما بقوا داخل البلد وهم على خلاف مع
قياداتهم بالتاكيد نتيجه للوضع الذي
اتخذته هذه القياده وخاصه حينما اصدرت
بيانا تدعو التحالف بقياده المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لاستمرار العدوان على
بلد دها وبالتالي المجتمع منقسم مثل ما ان
الاحزاب منقسمه على ذاتها اعتقد انه يدرك
بان كثير من اعضاء حزب الاصلاح ليسوا مع
توجه القياده التي اتخذت قرارها دون
الرجوع لهذه القواعد وبالتالي يؤخذ هذا
الخطاب في سياقه ونستطيع ان نقرا ما بين
سطوره لا اعتقد ان
هناك دعوه شامله بشموله ما وصلت الينا هذه
التق وان فرضنا جدلا ان ما تفضلت به صحيح
هو ايضا دعوه ل الاحتراب والاقتتال
الداخلي خالد الانسي اي صوره يعطيها هذا
الخطاب عن العلاقه بين تحالف الحوثي صالح
و من يعرفون بقبائل الطوق بين هؤلاء
القبائل وابنائها ما هي العلاقه بينهم
الان اولا في حقيقه الامر الصراع في اليمن
هو صراع ما بين بين شرعيه وتمرد صراع ما
بين الدوله وجماعات انقلابيه صراع ما بين
المجتمع اليمني وعصابات وليس حرب اهليه
وصراع مجتمعي كما يحاول ضيفك ان يصور هذا
الامر الذي حدث في اليمن هو انقلاب على
الشرعيه وانقلاب على الدوله من جماعات
تريد ان تستمر في السلطه بالقوه على
اسس متعدده كان سيناريو الرئيس المقلوع
منذ البدايه تحويل الصراع من صراع ي ما
بين الشرعيه وما بين التمرد والانقلاب الى
صراع مجتمعي في البدايه حاول ان يجعل منه
صراع طائفي مذهبي وفشل في هذا الامر ثم
حاول ان يجعل منه صراع مناطقي شمال وجنوب
وفشل في هذا الامر ثم حاول ان يجعل منه
صراع عرقي ما بين السلالات وفشل في هذا
الامر الان يحاول ان يحول الصراع الى صراع
حزبي
ويجعلها معركه حزبيه في في الداخل اما من
ناحيه العلاقه ما بين الحوثيين والقبائل
اعتقد ان ال ال
الخطابات الاخيره للرئيس المخلوع تبين ان
الحوثيين لم يكونوا سوى واجهه ولم يكونوا
سوى غلاف للانقلاب يشبهون يعني حركه تمر
في مصر ول حركه تم في مصر كانت حركه مدنيه
باعتبار طبيعه المجتمع سؤالي عن علاقه
التحالف الحوثي صالح
وخصوص مع
القبائل هي حقيقه الامر لا يوجد تحالف بين
الحوثي والقبائل والحوثي هو عباره عن اداه
وذراع
ميليشيات عسكري بيد الرئيس المخلوع
استخدمه من وقت مبكر وكانت هذه اكبر عمليه
نصب مارسها الرئيس المخلوع على اليمنيين
وعلى العالم وعلى دول الجوار الان من خلال
خطابات الرئيس المخلوع ومن خلال ما يحدث
ميدانيا ومن خلال ما تبينا كيمنيين ان كل
القيادات التي تقاتل في كل الجبهات وكل من
تولوا مناصب على انهم شخصيات حوثيه هم
اساسا ضباط في القوات الخاصه وفي الحرس
الجمهوري وفي الامن المركزي وقيادات في
المؤتمر الشعبي العام بمعنى ان الحوثي لم
يكن سوى محلل لهذا الانقلاب وسوى واجهه
ليس ليس اكثر اما على صعيد الوجود الحقيقي
هو لا يوجد بشكل حقيقي ولا يوجد له اي ثقل
لو رجعنا الى بدايه الانقلاب سنجد ان
الاعلان الدستوري الذي كان اعلنته اللجنه
الثوريه التي تتبع الحوثي قامت بحل
البرلمان وقامت باعلان خطوات معينه كل هذه
الخط طوات انتهت فعاد برلمان صالح وعاد
الوزراء صالح وعاد قاده صالح واصبحت كل
المؤسسات بيد الرئيس المخلوع وبيد حزب
الرئيس المخلوع علينا تصويب الصراع ان ما
يحدث في اليمن هو انقلاب يقود الرئيس
المخلوع ويمارس تشتكي تشتكي من هيمنه
الحوثي هذه القيادات تشتكي من هيمنه
الحوثي دكتور دكتور عادل عوامل عوامل
عديده تظافرت لا يمكن تجاهلها عوده هادي
والشرعيه الى اليمن وضع اقتصادي خانق في
كل البلاد خاصه في
صنعاء تعثر للحوثي وصالح في جبهات عديده
اهمها في المناطق الغربيه السؤال الذي
يطرح نفسه هل ما زالت خطابات الرجل تلق
صدا لدى الناس الذين تعودوا على خطاباته
على مدى فتره حكمه وبعد خلعه
ايضا اولا اخي العزيز طحن الاكاذيب
بهدف سهل ابتلاعها اعتقد انه هذا الزمن لم
يعد
زمانها الافعال على ارض الواقع هي التي
تعطي مصداقيتها والرئيس السابق مازال
يمتلك كثير من الاوراق الرابحه وهو يمتلك
ايضا القدره على ايجاد حلول سليمه اذا ما
مدت اليه يد السلام التي يدعو اليها هو
يدعو الى المصالحه في اكثر من خطاب لكن
للاسف الشديد الاطراف الاخرى لم تلتقط هذه
الدعوات هو دع لسلام وسماه سلام الشجعان
وهو ايضا وانا ادعو من خلال
قناتكم كل الاطراف السياسيه اليمنيه ان
علي عبد الله صالح على استعداد لان يجلس
على طاوله الحوار وعلى هذه الاطراف ان
تاتي الى طاوله الحوار لكي يناقشوا الوضع
اليمني وايضا هو يدعو المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ايضا للحوار وهو كثير من
خطاباته تشكيل جبهات جديده يتحدث عن 400
ال مقاتل والتوجه الى جبهات شماليه حدوديه
مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه كيف يكون هذا
خطاب ولهجه ولهجه تصالحيه
دكتور بالتاكيد بالتاكيد اخي العزيز اذا
كانت السعوديه قبل ان اتي الى الاستوديو
وهي تقصف يعني صنعاء منذ عامين متتاليا
ونحن في العام الثالث باعتقادي ان اي رجل
في مكانه لابد ان يدعو الى الحشد العام ب
هدف ايجاد نوع من التوازن خاصه وان اليمن
لا تمتلك في الوقت الراهن لا طيران ولا
تمتلك دفاعات قويه وهناك انتهاك لسيادتها
هو يدعو الى الحوار وعلى الاطراف الاخرى
على الاطراف الاخرى اكمل فقط على الاطراف
الاخرى تلتقط هذه الدعوات تلتقط هذه
الدعوات دعوات الدعوه الى الحوار والدعوه
الى المصالحه انا اقول من خلال قناتكم وهي
دعوه مفتوحه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
ولدول التحالف وكذلك لجميع القوى السياسيه
سواء الموجوده في الرياض او موجوده في
اسطنبول او حتى الموجوده في في عدن ان
الرجل يدعو دعوه حقيقيه للجلوس على طاوله
فهل لدم الاستعداد ان يول سؤال الى خالد
الانسي في اسطنبول هل يبدو لكم ان الرجل
يسعى الى السلام بعد هذا الخطاب باختصار
شديد هي حقيقه الامر سقطت كل اذوب الرئيس
المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح بما فيه دعوته
للسلام معتقلاته ملاه بالمعتقلين يعني من
من شباب الاحزاب ومن شباب الثوره ومن
قيادات حزب الاصلاح الان دعا مؤخرا الى
ملاحقه كل اصلاحي في كل قريه وفي كل عزله
واجتثاثه واعتقالهم فهذه ليست دعوات
للسلام والامر الاخر ما هي صفته لكي يدعوا
للسلام باي صفه هو يدعو للحوار يعني
هو يفترض انه قد خلع من السلطه ولم يعد له
اي اي صفه وصلت الفكره خالد الانسي الناشط
الحقوقي اليمني وعضو ائتلاف شباب الثوره
اليمنيه شكرا لك واشكر الدكتور عادل
الشجاع عضو اللجنه العامه في حزب المؤتمر
الشعبي العام اليمني جناح علي عبد الله
صالح